تصمت المقاومه فتشل اسرائيل
تضرب المقاومه
فتختبئ اسرائيل هذا الفرار الكبير في تل
ابيب لا وقت للتجوال فالصواريخ الفلسطينيه
فوق تتلقف بعضها القبه الحديديه لكن لا
قباب بحجم السماء فتصيبه وتخينه انه توازن
رعب ليس من طائرات ولا دبابات ما يسمى
الجيش الاسطوري لقد ادخلتهما المقاومه
المخابئ دون رصاصه واحده يوم ونصف لعله
الاثقل على دوله الاحتلال منذ تنفيذها
غاره فجر الثلاثاء على منازل ثلاثه قاده
من حركه الجهاد الاسلاميه فقتلتهم مع
نسائهم وعدد من اطفالهم وجيرانهم وبينما
راحت صور الاسعاف والدماء تشق ظلمه الليل
كانت اسرائيل تتاهب وتعد الدقائق في
الصباح اندفع عشرات الالاف الفلسطينيين
الى الشوارع متواعدين في الت فيما الاف
الاسرائيليين يجلون من غلاف غزه وقد تحول
الى قوس رعب متى يضربون كيف سيردون وطال
الانتظار اقفلوا المدارس والجامعات وفتحوا
الملاجئ من غزه الى حدود لبنان وعندما جاء
الرد لاحقتهم الصواريخ حتى تل ابيب عسقلان
استيراد اشكول وعشرات البلدات كلها تحت
الخطر وسط انباء عن تعطل الحركه في مطار
بن غوريون شن جيش الاحتلال غارات قال انها
استهدفت منصات صواريخ وسقط مدنيون
فلسطينيون لكن ضربات الصاروخيه استمرت
ليطرح الواقع اسئله كثيره عن جدول هجوم
الذي نفذته اسرائيل معلنه فيه استئناف
سياسه الاغتيالات وقد اندفع جنرالاتها من
وزير الدفاع الى قائد الامن الداخلي
لتفسيره وتبريره وحتى تضقيمه فهذا يقول
كانوا مسؤولين عن اطلاق الصواريخ واخروا
يتحدثوا عن انهم وراء نقل ما دعاه التوتر
من غزه الى الضفه الغربيه بينما يرى
الجميع ان الهجمات في الضفه تجاوزت
الجغرافيا الى حاله مقاومه من تنفيذ شبان
غير حزبيين تحركهم الفكره لا تعليمات
تنظيميه فعلى ما اذا فتحت ابواب النيران
براي مراقبين سيبدو ذلك محاوله لترميم
الصوره العسكريه الاسرائيليه في عيون
جمهورها وعليه فان سياسه الاغتيالات التي
اعتمدتها اسرائيل منذ نصف قرن تبدو اقربه
لنجاحات معنويه فلاستشهاد خليل الوزير ولا
ابو علي مصطفى وقاده حماس والجهاد وغيرهم
اوقف مسيرته من خلفهم اما الرهان الاخر من
الهجوم فهو شق صف المقاومه بمحاوله تحييد
حماس خصوصا والاستفرا الجهاد الاسلامي
الامر الذي رفضته غرفه العمليات المشتركه
وكراسه الصمت التام ثم الرد الجماعي وذاك
فصل خادم براي متابعين لم يكن بحاجه الى
وزير الطاقه
ليكشفه حين تحدث عن تحضير لاغتيال يحيى
السنوار ومحمد الضيف ما ازعج نتنياهو
وقادته عندما باحت الالسن بما في القلوب
لقد قتلت اسرائيل ثلاثه قاده عسكريين وثله
من الاطفال والنساء لكن الرضعه لم يتحقق
اذ تكفي كلمه او صمت لابقاء سكانها
مرتجفين وذاك ما يختصره الفلسطينيون
بعبارتين لا حياه مع الاحتلال وان عدتم
عدنا
[موسيقى]